the i-team's vanessa murphy has been
leading coverage she's here in the
studio with an exclusive update
denise and bryan we've uncovered new
video showing the moments before nathan
valencia's fight students i talked with
call the event unorganized and say there
was a lack of safety precautions taken
[Music]
it was very chaotic in there unlv
student nathan valencia participated in
this fraternity boxing match for charity
on november 19th this is video of
valencia in the red headgear the 20 year
old collapsed shortly after his fight
and died four days later his family says
from brain injuries
it was just fighting like there was no
like boxing involved
everybody was hitting each other in the
back of their heads unlv journalism
student david cruz says he recorded this
video at the event which according to
social media posts was held by the kappa
sigma fraternity valencia was a member
of sigma alpha epsilon his family tells
the i-team they believe the referee was
not a professional ref and in cruz's
video he is seen drinking what appears
to be alcohol throughout the night he
didn't look like a ref he was just like
somebody they pulled off from the side
to like stand there and be like all
right stop getting near each other video
also shows the ref looking at the
judge's table frequently ref wasn't
really participating he was more also
just a viewer just like
enthralled in the chaos of the event i
guess
[Music]
valencia's fight was the main event so
it was the last one anasaya was also
there earlier in the night she's in a
sorority which participated and she says
warning signs were present i remember my
sister who was fighting we were running
around trying to find her a pair of
gloves video shows fighter's head gear
needing to be adjusted repeatedly their
helmets kept falling off and people kept
swinging at their heads and
a lot of miscommunication in
that aspect valencia's family and their
attorney tell the i-team they believe
there was no professional medical help
on standby either i think there is
somebody to blame here and i think
the fraternity for
organizing a poor event and
not ensuring the safety of
their fighters the i-team reached out to
the kappa sigma fraternity which sent a
statement offering condolences to
valencia's family and the unlv community
a unlv spokesman tells the i-team the
university is looking into the incident
while the weigh-in for the boxers was
held on campus the actual boxing event
was held off campus at the sahara event
center metro police say they've
investigated licensing and it appears
the business is not at fault the i-team
has tried to identify the referee and as
of monday we have not been able to track
him down for a comment in a statement
valencia's parents said in part the
event has been held annually and was
well known to both unlv and the national
kappa sigma fraternity
we're young and we think we are
invincible at the time so a lot of those
safety precautions kind of get thrown
out the window and they shouldn't
especially on a sporting event like this
which is so dangerous
do you think this event should be held
ever again i don't i don't even i didn't
want to go
i didn't understand why it was being
held
according to the nevada state athletic
commission's website a referee is a
position which requires licensing
there's an application and there are
requirements and responsibilities i
reached out to the commission about this
fraternity boxing match and have not
received a response